I've always been obsessed with like
kindness I think it's one of the most
endearing qualities of a human humanity
the nice things like just saying thank
you for holding the door open all I like
a shaking of a hand when when you talk
somebody I think goes a long way moving
forward but yeah sure
player none battlegrounds better known
as pub G is a game where a hundred
people drop out of a plane onto an
island they try to get guns ammo meds
armor as fast as they can and stay with
inside the circle on the map and be the
last one alive
the world championship of pubsey is in
Berlin this year teams from all over the
world qualified to come here when you're
in like a top-level situation it's like
a symphony the competition is insane
everyone here is really good at the game
but we're ready for them gaming made
three times more money than the music
last year it's a hugely growing industry
the shots are ringing from that bottom
calm down
I definitely consider myself bad
[ __ ] for sure I feel [ __ ]
fantastic
this is battery ah this is puppy it's
not just for kids at home this is a
serious industry people should take it
seriously
[Music]
[Music]
my goal is to have a beach house with a
really nice big bathroom and hopefully I
can do that making a career out of it in
Peru gaming I play squad matches with my
team from around the world Grizz from
Florida Wieck from Germany faster from
Wales and I'm timid from Washington
[Music]
we all met just talking about pop G
online grizzly and I met just playing
poetry together we needed team members
for the team and we put out recruitment
posts that's how we met fast trill and
that's how we met wick my whole family
is watching I don't really have any
support my parents or my family just
don't understand that aspect of like
what you can become when they like being
a professional gamer etc etc my mom even
now is like school what about school and
I'm like mmm
like right now I'd rather try to push
and chase my dreams which is this and
it's insane that I'm even here being
having the opportunity to do so I named
myself timid cuz the name does kind of
fit me I'm not one to really go out of
my way to meet new people or the time
well this is the first time I've ever
been out of the United States so like
being in Germany something that's like
got so much history to it it's insane
hey I'm Jack also known as fast Phil I
play for honey badger nation and this is
me that t-shirt
well crop top and the leggings are
limited edition set so when Fox and Tim
was legal I used to do a lot of fox
hunting when it's the military I used a
lot of guns in that region
I was prep for almost every situation if
if we went to war if we went to any
conflict what would we do if we were
being interrogated or if we do if we saw
as a bomb wife what would we do if we
saw it you know if there's a possibility
of taking life
trying out new guns it's like trying
different flavors of sweets or like
different solve like beverages is sort
of completely different experience in
each gun you try
I'd say like I'm I like guns but do I
think they're necessary probably not I
don't think people play games
specifically to shoot people I think
it's it's the challenge of beating other
players that people play the game for
it's just a fun game how does it feel to
be like the god of this universe oh god
I'm not you know really I listen I
helped create a game mode that has
proven to be very popular I don't see
myself as anything over a god in this
game mode I'm just happy that people
enjoy a game I wanted to play a warm
welcome ladies and gentlemen here to
Berlin as we're alive from the
mercedes-benz arena for PGI this house
for hibachi he's trying to get her but
it was only 20 that could have made it
we have all three European teams that
doesn't play PvP in as much as they can
they're still in big money but they want
to get into big big money
[Music]
[Music]
believable ceremony we have every single
day to welcome these players we
qualified to be here by beating out 17
of the other best teams in North America
everyone here is really good at the game
for all of the hard work that we've put
in all the practice we've done this is
our chance to prove ourselves
my role in honey badger nation is purely
like the captain role I take care of my
team
and I'm also the in-game leader so any
decisions that we make in game that's
all through me it looks like it's all
eyes honey badger nation and low key
edge it's terrifying game of
hide-and-seek for now smoke goes in for
low key move forward he's he's in a bad
spot now he gets he gets found by fast
rail that does mean we're down to three
and Loki still alive
try and use the smoke hits the deck is
gene swords fast rail it's actually a
neon imagination doing very nicely here
grizzly doing well but not well enough
it's two teams
[Music]
hi you're a snake dude 100% yeah
slithering around what animal what they
know already unhooked you I don't know
that's it snake is your problem and hi
there are you like an owl
I just attack everything what is that
tiger that's at a time I just don't want
I don't care if I see somebody I fight a
grizzly bear
Grizz sure I don't know animals very
well so hi I am sexy people are getting
late
that's all on table check out want a
visitor bowtie okay believing with you
so there is o no
so we're thinking the ropey kangaroo
with a book you don't wanna get into
critical ya can since I'm nice I'm good
sexually to protecting what do you think
a bullet to help Dominator kill safety
pikas lor ways the pick up the rear is
being knocked as well appeal boys be
finished and this is black with all the
extra number 60 Pete will follow me
jumpin Jupiter
sort of continues while so my tomato
Pumas off oh my gosh Marik you actually
inside the building with cgw they have
to push them out see GWS in action is
horribly destroying WTF jeez game they
have to wait for them they have to move
now it's left them to accommodation I
get so emotional playing prop G and this
is one of the things about pub G as
opposed to fortnight I like fortnight I
like the speed of it I like that you can
jump in and just keep going but what I
really love about how to use the
emotions go down
Ubbe has a position he's got no other
game makes me feel like
[Applause]
so we'll probably be either seventh or
sixth
we were lacking a lot of basic team
chemistry that a lot of other teams have
a lot of the teams were rosters for well
over three four five eight months and
that's a long time to build team
chemistry we all had our fair share of
individual mistakes the individual
mistakes at top level can easily cost
you again
actually gonna know better but wishes
don't really get you that far these guys
like practice like 12 14 hours a day
continuously as a team we don't get paid
to practice but they get paid so it's
like it's rough coming forward into it's
all like a different level of approach I
guess
[Applause]
due to my work schedule and due to the
schedule of the players as well we're
limited to only playing about eight
hours per day if you compare that to
what a lot of the other players do and a
lot of the other teams do they do like
10 to 11 hours a day
brookey mahogany suitcase as well so how
do we go about yurchikhin taman Jaguar
currency guru game his own pro team of
sahaja yoga zumba
[Music]
[Music]
the entire experience is still surreal
this is the outfit that we all the
attendees got from being at Berlin I
played at the top level in the world the
first world championship of pub G being
able to go there is still like kind of
just surreal to me now that one's done
my plan is to just practice oh oh God
as much as I can get as good as I can
before the next qualifier the goal is to
be able to put my day job and live off
of a player salary from an organization
I think it'll happen within the next two
months hopefully
we'll be holding like a needs happiness
I think happiness is one of the most
beautiful things in life John back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no aunt upendra Oh Dana ha motor
stolen a drink over da sé como es o da
da da da cunha highway coccidia Mucha
Mucha agua Seneca Doane English me that
really woman Amazon will get you into
poverty
vanadium
[Music]